for our rocket in an external force we
have the rocket equation which we wrote
as mass of the rocket now remember this
is a function of time times the
derivative of the rocket dr/dt and we
also have this second term that came
from the ejecting fuel now from our mass
conservation equation we can rewrite
this equation as a differential
relationship that the change of mass of
the fuel in time is equal to minus the
change of the rocket it doesn't matter
which side we put the minus sign on so
now I want to interpret this equation in
a different way and it will come back to
what we mean by our system let's first
off bring this other term over to this
side so we have plus DM r DT U and
that's equal to M R DV R DT now
separately let's make this substitution
again and go back to our fuel term so
that's minus DM f dt u equals M R DV r
DT now notice that over here we have
mass times the acceleration of the
rocket so if we just rethought our
system as simply the rocket M R then we
have two forces acting on the rocket the
external force might be the
gravitational field but we have a new
term here which we're going to refer to
as thrust and so our thrust can be
thought of as an external force simply
on the rocket as a system and that's
equal to minus DF DT you now again if I
chose J hat up let's just look at this
in components then our thrust
as a vector will write it as a y
component is equal to minus DM fuel DT
now what is that relative speed well the
fuel is being ejected backwards so
that's minus mu J hat the external force
by the way would be minus mg J hat if
it's near the surface of the earth so we
have another minus u J hat and we see
that we have a positive thrust force in
the vertical direction that is giving us
an additional force other than the
gravitational field and in Cartesian
court in our unit vectors here we have
minus mg plus DM fuel DT times U is
equal to M R DV Y DT of the rocket and
so this is the rocket equation in
components